hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from the fiday women's
Grand Swiss tournament that finished um
a week ago it's a game between Dutch
International master elen rubar and um
uh Armenian grandm elen danelian and
it's a really wild attacking game you
guys will enjoy this one and it will be
a nice refreshing um change of scenery
after that game that I've played so
let's check it out Elena has the white
piece and she opens with Pawn to E4 H
sorry about
that uh we have Pawn to D6 uh going for
the pier defense and now Pawn to D4 we
have Knight to F6 Knight to C3 and to G6
the main line of the Pats and Alena
challenges it with the Austrian attack
Pawn to F4 we have Bishop to G7 and now
Knight to F3 there is a game uh udith
poar played it in 2012 against Magnus
Carlson she played Bishop to D3 and then
after some F50 moves Magnus won that
game but here we have Knight Knight to
F3 we have castles and pawn to A3 now a
fairly rare move uh but it has been
played um a couple times actually by
former world champion vishan Anand so
here Pawn to C5 uh D captures and now
Queen to A5 now also with ideas of
capturing on C5 but basically baiting
white to play Pawn to B4 it's not really
a bait as it's always the strongest move
so Pawn to B4 Queen back to d8 and now
Bishop to D2 idea of course is that if
black wants to m of White's Pawn
structure on the queen side white will
get this Central advancement of the E5
pawn and uh there are a couple of games
that reach this position where Knight
the H5 was played but here we have Pawn
captures on C5 and it is now as of move
nine that we have a completely new game
now alinaa of course advances the pawn
to E5 we have Knight F to D7 and now
Bishop to D3 we have Knight to C6 and
now you might expect something like Pawn
to B5 but now Elena goes for the King
right away with Pawn to H4
uh C captures on B4 and now Knight to E4
and it would be a bit too dangerous to
maybe grab another pawn and allow Pawn
to H5 so instead Elena uh plays Pawn to
H5 herself and now a captures on B4 so
okay Elena is up a pawn and she has a
safer King so Elena will have to show
that her attacking idea works we have
Knight to B6 and now Queen to E2 uh
Bishop to G4 pinning the Knight here and
Pawn to C3 it's a very important move
you don't want to see this Knight land
on D4 so Pawn to C3 and now we have
Queen to C8 here
actually if uh if black just wants to
fight for for equality uh you could just
trade here with Bishop captures captures
and the bishop captures on E5 uh but
even even though it's uh it seems like
you've um grabbed the pawn and you
you're going to be doing okay it it can
still be potentially dangerous of course
you're not going to capture and allow
Knight captures on E5 to attack the
queen and the bishop then you lose the
bishop uh you will move the king king to
E2 and now the bishop has to move as the
bishop on D3 is defended and once the
bishop moves you will play Pawn to B5
kick away the Knight to this ugly B8
square and now start the attack against
the black king so it again it would be
very dangerous looks like okay maybe
you're just playing for a draw uh but
may maybe that would be playing right
into White's hands so Queen to C8 by
Lena and now Knight to F2 putting
pressure on that Bishop here so Bishop
to f F the queen from C8 nicely
defending the bishop and elen just
trades we have Bishop captures Queen
captures and now only Now Pawn to B5 so
going back to B8 would be too passive
and it would be uh pretty much giving
white a winning winning game so Knight
goes back to d8 you have to be able to
reach that E6 square and now Pawn to G4
now you don't have to start with Knight
to D4 this is also uh playable and maybe
perhaps even faster H captures and G4
Knight to D4 attacking the queen on F5
and queen to D7 and now further
advancing the pawn with Pawn to H5 and
it's now a very very dangerous position
for black very hard to defend and you
probably could survive this with engine
perfect play and to give you an example
of that you have to play Pawn to F5 to
survive this and then after H6 attacking
the bishop Bishop h8 Knight captures on
G4 and after it captures H7 check King
F7 uh Rook H6 you're going to get the E4
go after G6 this just a Terri position
for for black and it's not going to be
uh well like I said maybe if you find
engine perfect moves if you for example
move the Knight E6 check just wins uh
you cannot trade the Knight with this
because then Queen to E4 and there's no
stopping Queen captur on G6 so it's just
a disgusting position to play however it
is the only way to play it but in the
game G captures on H5 was played and now
Elina just gets this F5 push in uh both
of the pawns are defended so not nothing
to be done there Queen to D5 going after
the E5 pawn and now Pawn to F6
sacrificing material H but not really e
captures on F6 now Rook captures on H5
uh defending on E5 and now look at this
if you play F captures on E5 which seems
like it's possible then comes Knight to
F5 and if Queen to E6 because well what
do you do Knight to A7 check will win
the queen on D5 so you have to move the
queen queen to E6 now just Queen
captures on G4 threatening Che Checkmate
and that's pretty much it if Queen G6
you're going to play even better Knight
E7 is Checkmate so uh you're going to
play that so after Rook captures on H5
Rook to E8 was played uh but now look at
this Knight captures on G4 boldly going
um forward as even with the queen and
king still on the E file facing that
Rook Knight to C4 and now we have
queenside castles we have Knight
captures on E5 and now Knight to F5 even
allowing Knight to D3 check which would
um win Elina the the the White Queen so
that's exactly what happens Knight to D3
check and here elen sacrifices the queen
queen captures on D3 Queen captures on
D3 and now it's actually a forced
Checkmate in six that's why Alena
sacrific her Queen feel free to pause
the video and try to find this exact um
sequence while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
some nice moves like maybe Rook to G1 or
maybe even Knight captures and G7 those
are all very nice although they're not
winning by force Knight captures on F6
is just a ma in six and there's uh
nothing you can do about it the point is
that if you move the king uh then you
get Rook to h8 you sacrifice the rook
and once the bishop captures now Bishop
to H6 check and look at this bishop G7
and Bishop captur and G7 uh resulting in
this very very strange Checkmate sort of
a sort of an L-shaped sort of a knight
pattern jump Checkmate I don't think
I've ever seen this and I don't know if
this has a name so uh would be very nice
but in the actual game Knight captures
on F6 she took on F6 Bishop captures on
F6 and now the other rug joins the
attack Rook to G1 check King to f8 and
now Bishop to H6 check and he was in
this position on move 32 that Elina
danelon resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here once you
block and this is your only move then
comes Bishop captures on G7 check King
to G8 and now of course Rook to h8 will
be Checkmate so uh very very very strong
attack um uh maybe something if you guys
face the Pet's defense a lot maybe go
for the Austrian attack you can see a a
lot can go wrong for black and if you if
you're willing to play uh you know such
U aggressive moves keep your king in the
center of the board just push the H Pawn
you know just push G4 uh sacrifice the G
Pawn push the H Pawn you know just March
forward maybe this is the opening for
you uh so yeah another another brilliant
game by elen taking down a
grandmas uh as we've seen her do so so
many times before uh she's um on her way
you know collecting Norms she she got
five out of 11 in this tournament which
I think she probably is not too happy
about as um you know uh we've seen her
play against a very very strong OPP
position and she can really play some
strong chess so she will probably try
harder
in the next one uh but yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to wish a very happy birthday to
shaie and I would like to thank K Alis
rodella Andre sh Edmund Freeman and
Kevin Clark for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World as so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day